In this video we will be discussing viewing scan details. You can view details for running or
completed scans. The information available changes depending on the scan status. To view scan details
you can navigate through the various tabs. Firstly we have the dashboard which gives you your issues,
severity, trends, scanned URLs, most serious vulnerabilities and total issues. If we select
the timeline tab and the scan is running we can monitor the scan through its various stages. If
the scan is completed we can also scroll through the timeline and review all of the events. The issues
tab will detail the specific vulnerabilities that have been located during the scan. This is
categorized based on the severity or the confidence level. Additionally we have filters by new or
regressed issues. The scan URLs tab will detail all URLs that have been audited.
Scan stats will detail what has occurred during the scan in terms of the severity,
the traffic, any changes relative to previous scans, and additional details such as a scanning
machine used and scanner version. The settings tab will detail the settings that we applied for the
site and will show his information such as the URL that we're scanning, the protocols, the scan configuration,
any extensions that we applied, logins that we applied and also the recurring scan schedule.
If we select the reporting tab once the scan is complete we can review which reports we would like
to download. And finally we have the logging tab which will detail firstly the event log and additionally the scan debug log.
The event log can be useful to review once the scan is completed. You can also download the event log should you require it for support issues.
The same applies to the debug log which will be required by Portswick support should they need to review your scan for any issues.
Thank you.